[Musique]
des zones ravagées par la violence des
courants la tempête ali alex a fait de
nombreux dégâts
d'abord je voudrais dire ma solidarité
avec tous ceux qui y vivent cela
évidemment les familles des victimes
mais mais plus généralement tous ceux
qui aujourd'hui sont un peu dans la
désolation avec ce qui s'est passé à
saint martin vésubie la rivière a
retrouvé son lit dévoilant un panorama
ravagé ici la caserne de gendarmerie en
partie avalé par l'isu je ne vous cache
pas notre vive inquiétude sur le bilan
définitif de cet épisode comme saint
martin vésubie une douzaine de how sont
entièrement ou partiellement coupés du
monde plus de routes plus d'électricité
plus d'eau plus de communication que
toujours huit disparus certains si j'ose
dire et 10 disparus que nous devons
confirmer parce que je suis allé avec le
premier ministre et les élus locaux sur
place c'est effectivement des images de
grande dévastation
depuis son hospitalisation vendredi des
interrogations circulent sur le réel
état de santé du président américain
des proches collaborateurs de donald
trump ont révélé après coup leur grande
inquiétude
il a eu de la fièvre et son taux
d'oxygène dans le sang a chuté
brutalement
je peux vous dire qu'avec les médecins
nous étions très préoccupés
il ya une petite part d'égoïsme dans
chacun d'entre nous et puis que cette
part d'égoïsme est passé c'est très
français
il ya la volonté de se dire mais
pourquoi on n'a pas pris nos
responsabilités et souvent se tourner
vers ses dirigeants pour dire pourquoi
vous n'avez pas été courageux je me sens
beaucoup mieux maintenant nous
travaillons dur pour que je me remette
tout à fait je pense que je serai
bientôt de retour
il sera donc élu président de la
république l'ifop et le jdd ont testé
plusieurs configurations possibles en
fonction des candidats avec ou pas
l'union de la gauche et pour le coup
quelles que soient les situations c'est
toujours le duel macron le pen au coude
à coude entre 24 et 27 %
la structuration politique de notre pays
elle se fait désormais entre celles et
ceux qui prônent leur enfer rendre
enfermement sur soi celles et ceux qui
prônent parfois la haine de l'autre des
autres et puis celles et ceux qui
prendre justement ce progrès et avancer
ensemble
là c'est avec anne hidalgo pour
représenter la gauche qui monterait à 9%
qui ferait baisser un peu jean luc
mélenchon et qui ferait baisser un peu
emmanuel macron quinzaine de
candidatures les questions d'incarnation
sont totalement prématurée et d'ailleurs
si on pouvait ne pas tomber dans ce
piège là je pense qu'il faut travailler
beaucoup
patiemment emmanuel macron détaille son
plan de lutte contre les séparatismes
avec un adversaire déclaré force est de
constater qu'il y à un islamisme radical
priorités du chef de l'état
l'éducation notamment pour éviter
l'endoctrinement religieux dès le plus
jeune âge votre ministère et est
concerné très concernée par les mesures
et dans cette lutte l'école sera
désormais obligatoire dès 13 ans tu fais
là près des trois ans je fais la
précision pour les gens qui nous
regardent l'école et plus l'instruction
c'est important de le préciser fait de
son moral de personnes parce que ça fait
des dizaines d'années
moi qui finit en 82 que personne n'a
pris la mesure de ce qui s'est passé
c'est l'occasion pour les groupes
radicaux extrémistes bien tout
simplement de retirer les enfants
d'écoles et de les soumettre
pas tellement alors aux familles un peu
aux familles mais surtout à des
structures clandestines que nous
cherchons à fermer on a voté en ce
dimanche en nouvelle-calédonie et le non
à l'indépendance l'a emporté avec très
exactement 53,26 % des voix puis à
marine le pen qui est un peu perdu 50 va
pas chercher un paquet de cigarettes un
peu de coke ou un peu d'alcool j'ai vu
un peu difficile pour elle de faire de
la politique d'avoir un cap
ils ont majoritairement confirmé leur
souhait de maintenir la nouvelle
calédonie dans la france en tant que
chef de l'état
j'accueille cette marque de confiance
dans la république avec un profond
sentiment de reconnaissance va falloir
couper tout ça au montage mais après
tout j'assume mes
faudra qu'elle porte plainte et à ce
moment là je donnerai mes sources